well what happens when all people get
together in a group you know we talked
about that last time when we talked
about Kierkegaard's idea that as soon as
you get a bunch of people together no
matter how truthful they are all as
individuals instantly the crowd is not a
truthful thing and you know there there
are there are real reasons for that real
psychological reason so there's the
famous ash experiments I hope that those
are the right experiments a sch about
line length you know so you draw two
lines on the board and they're the same
length and you get the the crowd to you
know collaborate with you and you ask
some poor sucker who doesn't know about
the game to play and you know you ask
one person and they say no those lines
are different in length and you ask
another person they say well yeah
they're quite different in length and
another person says yeah this sure I can
see the difference in length and then
you ask the poor pigeon you know are
they different in length and he says yes
you know and you can understand why it's
like if all those other people are
saying it is either there is either
something wrong with all of them which
seems unlikely or he's the victim of a
conspiracy which is a little on the
paranoid side but happens to actually be
true in this case or he's just not
looking at it right and you might think
well the humble thing to think is he's
wrong and so you know the fact that
somebody might go along with the crowd
you know you can you can you can blame
that on their on their ability to be
social and conventional which in many
ways is a huge advantage because if you
are all antisocial and unconventional
you know I mean there'd be a good chunk
of you in jail and we certainly wouldn't
be having this you know delightful
peaceful conversation that we're having
so you know you don't want to
underestimate the utility of
conventionality to too much of a degree
anyway so there's this funny story I
read once I don't think it's true but it
might be where a psychology class got
together and decided they play a trick
on the professor and the trick was that
he would walk back and forth they and
and the trick was that they wouldn't pay
any attention to him at all if he was on
the left side of the room you know they
talked a bit and look look up and if he
was on the right side of the room then
they'd really focus in and pay it
and the story goes that by the you know
by several weeks of this little trick
they had him like lecturing right beside
the door you know and he wouldn't move
from that spot and so the reason I'm
telling you that is because it's pretty
obvious that people can respond to the
cues that a crowd is delivering you know
and a good speaker does that right so a
good speaker does a variety of things
and one is that never talks to the to
the crowd per se
you know you pick out specific
individuals and talk to them and they're
sort of reflective of the crowd and then
you can tell if everybody's
understanding and the other thing that a
good speaker does is pay attention to
the damn responses of the crowd because
you know if lecture is really a dialogue
even though the audience is only
emitting nonverbal the nonverbal
elements of the conversation those
nonverbal elements those damn things are
important so you want to stay in touch
with the nonverbal communication